-You ever see a photo
in the news
and think that headlines
should be different?
Well, we're gonna take care
of that right now.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was,
"Dr. Fauci says U.S.
is out of pandemic phase."
Yep.
The headline can definitely
be improved because if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been,
"Dad does mic drop
after destroying eulogy."
[ Laughter ]
He's like...
[ Applause ]
-Come on!
-Up next, this headline says,
"Queen Elizabeth beams
at Royal Windsor Horse Show."
The headline could've been,
"Wedding guest gets really into
'Little bit softer now'
portion of 'Shout.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh, oh, way-oh ♪
-This next headline was,
"Biden's job approval numbers
continue to slide."
Headline could've been,
"Father of the bride
clearly taking a leak
in the shrubs."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Ooh!"
-"Oh!"
Next headline was, "BTS holds
White House press briefing."
Headline could've been,
"New FDA commissioners
announce plans to make butter
35% smoother by 2024."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The next headline was,
"Harris announces plan
to cancel
federal student loans."
Headline could've been,
"Mom accidentally walks in
on son's
'personal computer time.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Mom!
It's my personal --
it's my personal computer time."
-Throuple.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Next headline was,
"Prime Minister Trudeau
attends ceremony."
Headline could've been,
"Dad gets just a little high
for PTA meeting."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, this headline was,
"Pope Francis
opens doors for women."
Headline could've been,
"Drunk friend gives final,
reassuring look before eating it
on water skis."
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."
We have a great show.